[Applause]
bombshell new report by Politico
claiming House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
clashed with Judiciary Chairman Jerry
Nadler over whether to begin impeachment
hearings against President Trump because
instead of impeachment she wants to see
the president in prison Politico
reporting quote Nadler press pelosi to
allow his committee to launch an
impeachment inquiry against Trump Pelosi
stood firm reiterating that she isn't
open to the idea of impeaching Trump at
this time I don't want to see him
impeached I want to see him in prison
Pelosi comments reportedly happening
during a closed-door meeting with top
Democrats on Tuesday night you know what
this sounds like to me she's just
throwing the left of bone to make him
seem like yeah I'm really yeah really
badly but there is a school of thought
on the left that that they won't be able
to impeach because the Senate will never
vote along those lines they have
thoughts on the left that's those alert
and so but they're like keep pushing on
the court system because the court
system but once we beat him out of
office then he'll go to jail there is
there is a school of thought there I the
thing is about her if I believe that she
said this they're not really denying it
like yeah I could imagine it the thing
is that that democratic debate is in
three weeks and it's sort of like
remember when Newt Gingrich called
was it Mitt Romney a liar at the debate
in South Carolina remember where did you
go from there
right so if Nancy Pelosi the leader of
the Democrats is saying I want to put
them in prison imagine what the other
Democrats are gonna try to do to top
that so that they can get ahead well let
me let me interpret for all of you
because I think she's not saying
anything about impeachment I think what
she's saying really is we need to beat
him in 2020 right and then once he's out
of the White House with all its
protections at that point we can look
and see what prosecution is possibly
just say no I agree with you it's not
saying throw them in jail there's only
one politician I know of who throws
their political once talks about
throwing their political opponents in
jail oh I know his name but I mentioned
then there's the obvious possibility
peggy noonan in The Wall Street Journal
the other day said
just have the house century or a
Lawrence tribe is saying well you can do
more you can have a sense of the house
and maybe condemn him everybody's
looking for some way to deal with this
issue but we don't have an answer what
do you think prison politics now
prison politics the Democrats are going
to go to the debate and say that Trump
should be in Gitmo and that's that's
where they're gonna send him I can't
believe that she said it she probably
leaked it to politically she probably
just letting you know that I really
think you should be in prison really
intensive everybody wants somebody to be
in prison right at this table no let me
take you you know I mean it's like you
know how I feel about maroon 5 I would
like to see the room five in prison no
maximum-security away from any recording
studio I think she probably just threw
it off like she was like - she just
threw it out there and you know I used
the same philosophy words versus deeds
with Trump that you do with Pelosi
people just say stuff and they say a lot
of stuff and it's just like it's off the
cuff Trump could have you know as
commander-in-chief said you know let's
lock Hillary up he didn't do it he
didn't do it now she he did well she
didn't her locker since he's been
present he hasn't said I think you
missed some of these rallies you love so
much he's still saying it you love them
too